[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
Kos and today I bring you a statue that
is part of a storyline that you guys
know oh so well because it's my favorite
storyline of The Incredible Hulk
it's from the Planet Hulk storyline and
World War Hulk storyline I bring you
sideshows Premium Format scar son of
Hulk that is a huge statue
it's a powerful statute but let me give
you a little background about scar so
the Incredible Hulk fell in love with
another warrior on a planet of Sekar and
when he fell in love with her they
foster the child but a bomb that was on
the ship they got him to the planet
wasn't a bomb it was a nuclear reactor
the fusion reactor on the Quinjet that
blew up and his wife died
also he thought now she had the old
power the old force and in that the baby
was in a cocoon the Hulk didn't know so
the Hulk left the planet in search of
revenge that's how we got World War Hulk
but his son was still alive so he was in
a cocoon and he was born out of the
cocoon but he was at the size of a
preteen and in less than a year he was
the size of a young teenager he grew
very rapidly because he has the gamma
radiation and he has the old force the
old power so then he's able to tap into
both of these powers so Galactus
threatened the planet he defended his
planet but he still was hell-bent on
revenge for the Incredible Hulk because
he felt abandoned he felt left alone he
felt that if his father was there to
defend the planet that his planet
wouldn't have been in such peril well he
gets to Planet Earth and he confronts
his father while he loses handily but
he's a very formidable opponent scar has
beat the likes of the juggernaut by
punching him straight into orbit his
foot Red Hulk and a ton of other heroes
on his quest to get revenge against the
hope but they finally came to terms as
the Hulk well at the period of time he
was d powered and he was David Banner
and he got a chance to you know talk
with scar and find out what's going to
bond with
son so let's get into this statue
now this statue is the e^x version that
means it has the switch out the switch
out for this statue is the battle ax and
the sword now when the sword is being
used there's a sheath that goes in the
back now it has a sword help that will
be displayed when the axe is in play but
when the sword is in play you can remove
the sword out so the sword is not being
shown
when you see the pitches above you can
see the many ways that you could display
this statue
the statue is very heavy this is one
that had been in my collection and was
on display so the unboxing isn't like a
regular unboxing it's more of a
displaying I'm showing you my statue
because I love this statue it's
mixed-media so you guys know when I talk
about mixed-media its material also you
have the resin statue
he's standing on rocky base he's in a
dynamic pose he has the 9th and the
sword or the knight and that acts ready
for action his hair is in sway and it's
a very solid piece see his grain isn't
as vibrant as other Incredible Hulk
statues because remember he's a
variation of the gamma radiation power
because at the same time he's infused
with the old force so this is the part
of the video when I'm an action to hit
that light following subscribe and also
hit that joy but if that joy but you
know where the joint button is the joint
button is right there at the bottom and
also go to
Gaming dotnet we have a ton of opinion
pieces we have a ton of giveaways we
have a giveaway going on right now
is the whole did that for you
sweepstakes where we're giving away a
Xbox Series X so follow the Lord's
Sunday at 1:00 p.m. to get all the
information on that giveaway becoming a
member of the realm and also joining our
patreon can't wait to see you next week
when I bring you a statue that I was
supposed to give you this week I'm
looking right at him he's a god and I'm
pretty sure you know exactly who he is
stay collecting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]